good morning John I woke up this morning
at nine o'clock this is me looking at
myself the viewscreen and thinking my
hair is a bird your argument is invalid
then I went for a run and then looked at
some fish and then because it was so
frakkin hot and humid I jumped into a
pool I'm in Florida it's very hot
everywhere the air isn't conditioned
well your frigid air of sweet salvation
and because the inside is so preferable
to the outside no one is outside
everyone stuck in there 4,000 cubic foot
SUVs and that includes me the people at
enterprise rental car excitedly
announced that I was getting a quadruple
upgrade to a real big truck it is indeed
real big though in Montana we don't call
something a truck unless you can throw a
bull elk in the back of it I call this
thing a boat before I call it a truck
I lived here most of my life and then
having moved away I realized that there
were a lot of things wrong with it now
I'm realizing that I kind of had a
rather selective negative memory about
this place yes it is unnecessarily hot
yes the Sun is ridiculously bright
somebody turn this down the cars are big
and you need to have one all the time to
get anywhere all the cups are made of
styrofoam and the fire ants yeah the
fire ants are bad you should not go poke
fire ant mounds because well Wow yeah
okay yeah I got stung but I can't really
say I didn't serve that one but they're
also things I love sweet tea waffle
house and that giant insane son breeds a
humongous variety of life that we just
can't compare with in Montana and sure
the humidity will suck away your will to
live but sometimes it's nice to have a
reason to jump into a giant pool of
water but now that the Sun is going down
and the temperature is approaching
bearable at least I realize that the
reason I feel like I miss Florida now
isn't because I miss Florida it's
because I missed the reason that I'm
here right now and I'm here to watch a
friend get married and so of course all
of my old college friend from Florida
are also here to watch my friend get
married it's a reunion of sorts several
people who I haven't seen in almost 10
years which is how long has been since I
graduated from college which is
extraordinarily upsetting most of the
best reasons to love a place our people
and when I walked out of the Tallahassee
Regional Airport and the thick hot air
was blowing through the palm trees the
thing I think about first isn't the
traffic or the sprawl it's actually the
reason why I had to walk away from the
pool because I didn't want my friends to
hear me get all sappy about this stuff
but the reason that I love Florida is
because of the people
who I loved when I was here and who I
will of course keep on loving forever
John I'll see you on Wednesday
fries are tied to the fries are tiny cuz
they're sticking to Gretel
being tasty
oh oh we did it Wow oh now it's your
bike's there was look compression
like a snake swallowing an egg